Can we actually predict stock
prices with machine learning?
Investors make educated
guesses by analyzing data.
They'll read the news study of the
company history industry trends.
There are lots of data points
that go into making a prediction.
The prevailing theory is that stock prices
are totally random and unpredictable.
A blindfolded monkey throwing
darts at a newspaper,
financial pages could select a portfolio
that would do just as well as one
carefully selected by experts.
But that raises the question,
why do top firms like Morgan Stanley and
Citi group higher quantitative analysts
to build predictive models?
We have this idea of a trading floor being
filled with adrenaline and abused men
with loose ties running around
yelling something into a phone.
But these days are more likely to see
rows of machine learning experts quietly
sitting in front of computer screens.
In fact,
about 70% of all hoarders on Wall
Street are now placed by software.
We're now living in the age
of the algorithm. Hello world,
it's Saroj and today we're going to build
a deep learning model to predict stock
prices, records a prices for traded
commodities go back thousands of years.
Merchants along popular silk routes
would keep records of traded goods to try
and predict price trends so that they
could benefit from them and finance.
The field of quantitative analysts is
about 25 years old and even now it's still
not fully accepted, understood or
widely used, just like Google plus.
It's the study of how certain variables
correlate with stock price behavior.
One of the first attempt at this
was made in the 70s by two British
statisticians and box and Jenkins
using mainframe computers.
The only historical data they had access
to where prices and volume they call
their model or Rema, and at the time
it was slow and expensive to run,
but by the eighties things
started to get interesting.
Spreadsheets were invented so
that firms could model companies,
financial performance and automated data
collection became a reality and with
improvements in computing power
models could analyze data much faster.
It was a renaissance on Wall
Street. People were excited
about the possibilities.
They started showing up at seminars
and discussing their techniques.
You should see what's going on
at the bigger firms. I mean,
I know all the information,
but all of this quickly died down.
Once people realize that what works is
actually a very valuable secret. Alright,
get the fuck off. Since then, the most
successful quants have gone underground.
In the past few years,
we've seen lots of academic
papers published using
neural nets to predict stock
prices with varying degrees of success.
But until recently,
the ability to build these models has
been restricted to academics who spend
their days writing very complex code.
Now with libraries like tensorflow,
anyone can build powerful predictive
models trained on massive data sets.
So let's build our own model using
kiosk with a tensorflow backend.
For our training data,
we'll be using the daily closing
price of the s and p 500 from January,
2002 August,
2016 this is a series of data points
indexed in time order or a time series.
Our goal will be to predict the closing
price for any given after training,
we can load our data using
a custom load data function.
It essentially just reads our CSV file
into an array of values and normalizes
them. Rather than feeding those
values directly into our model.
Normalizing them improves convergence.
We use this equation to normalize each
value to reflect percentage changes from
the starting points,
so we'll divide each price by the initial
price and subtract one when our model
later makes a prediction will denormalize
the data using this formula to get a
real world number out of it.
To build our model,
we'll first initialize it as sequential
since it will be a linear stack of
layers. Then we'll add our first layer,
which is an LSTM layer. So what is this?
Let's back up for it.
Recognizes feet single Eric's with me.
You don't have to say what you did I
already know sound out from it's easy.
Call the words forward,
but could we sing them
words?
No. The reason for this is because
we learned these words in a sequence.
It's conditional memory. We can access
a word if we access the words before it.
Memory matters when we have sequences
are thoughts have persistence,
but feedforward neural nets don't they
except a fixed size vector as input like
an image.
So we couldn't use it to say predict
the next frame and a movie because that
would require a sequence of image
vectors as inputs, not just one.
Since the probability of a certain event
happening would depend on what happened
every frame before it.
We need a way to allow information
to persist and that's why we'll use a
recurrent neural net. Recurrent Nets can
accept sequences of vectors as inputs,
so recall that for
feedforward neural nets,
the hidden layers weights are
based only on the input data,
but in a recurrent net.
The hidden layer is a combination of the
input data at the current time step and
the hidden layer at a previous time step.
The hidden layer is constantly
changing as it gets more inputs.
And the only way to reach these hidden
states is with the correct sequence of
inputs. This is how memory is incorporated
in and we can model this process
mathematically.
So this hidden state at a given time
step is a function of the input at that
same time step modified by a weight
matrix like the ones used in feed forward
nets added to the hidden state of the
previous time step multiplied by its own
hidden state to hidden state matrix,
otherwise known as a transition matrix
and because this feedback loop is
occurring at every time
step in the series,
each hidden state has traces of not only
the previous hidden state but also of
all of those that proceeded it.
That's why we call it recurrent in a
way we can think of it as copies of the
same network,
each passing a message to the next.
So that's the great thing
about recurrent nets.
They're able to connect previous
data with the present task,
but we still have a problem.
Take a look at this paragraph.
It starts off with I hope Senpai will
notice me and end with she is my friend.
He is my Senpai.
Let's say we wanted to train a model
to predict this last word given all the
other words.
We need the from the very beginning of
the sequence to know that this word is
probably Senpai, not something like buddy
or mate and irregular recurrent nets.
Memories become more subtle
as they fade into the past.
Since the error signal from later time
steps doesn't make it far enough back in
time to influence it.
Network at earlier time steps during
backpropagation Yoshua Bengio called this
the vanishing gradient problem in one of
his most frequently cited papers titled
Learning Longterm dependencies
with grading. Dissent is difficult.
Love the bluntness.
A popular solution to this is
a modification to recurrent
nets called long short
term memory.
Normally neurons are units that apply an
activation function like a sigmoid to a
linear combination of their
inputs in an LSTM recurrent net.
We instead replaced these neurons
with water called memory cells.
Each cell has an input gate on output
gate and an internal state that feeds into
itself across time steps with
a constant weight of one.
This eliminates the vanishing gradient
problem since any gradient that flows
into this self recurrent unit during
back prop is preserved indefinitely since
errors multiplied by one
still have the same value.
Each gate is an activation
function like sigmoid.
During the forward pass the input gate
learns went to late activation pass into
the cell and the Applegate learns
went to let activation pass out of it.
During the backward pass the Applegate
Lauren's went to let air flow into the
cell and the implicate ones went to let
it flow out of the cell through the rest
of the network. So despite everything
else in a recurrent net staying the same,
doing this more powerful update equation
for our hidden state results in our
network, being able to remember longterm
dependencies. So for our LSTM layer,
we'll set our input dimension to one
and say we want 50 units in this layer.
Setting returned sequences to true means
this layer is output is always fed into
the next layer. All Its activations can
be seen as the sequence of predictions.
This first layer has made
from the inputs sequence.
We'll add 20% dropout to this layer.
Then initialize our second layer as
another LSTM with 100 units and set return
sequence to false on it.
Since it's output is only fed to the
next layer at the end of the sequence,
it doesn't output a
prediction for the sequence.
Instead a prediction director
for the whole input sequence,
we'll use the linear dense layer to
aggregate the data from this prediction
vector into one single value.
Then we can compile our model using a
popular loss function called mean squared
error and use grading dissent as
our optimizer labeled rms prop.
We'll train our model
with the fic function.
Then we can test it to see what it
predicts for the next 50 steps at several
points in our graph and
visualize it using map plot line.
It seems that for a lot of the price
movements, especially the big ones,
there is quite the correlation between
our model's prediction and the actual
data. So time to make some
money and play some too,
but we'll our model be able to correctly
predict the closing price 100% of the
time.
Hell to the no.
It's an analytical tool to help us make
educated guesses about the direction of
the market that is slightly better
than random. So to break it down,
recurrent nets can model sequential data.
Since at each time step,
the hidden state is effected by the
input and the previous hidden state.
A solution to the vanishing gradient
problem for recurrent nets is to use long
short term memory cells to remember
longterm dependencies and we can use LSTM
networks to make predictions for time
series data easily using carrots.
And tensorflow.
The winter of the coding challenge from
the last video is the Shaw bought you.
We shall use transfer learning to
create a classifier for cats and dogs.
He chose a layer from a pretrained
tensorflow model and built his own custom
convolutional net on top of it to make
training much faster. Wizard of the week,
and the runner up is Jeshurun.
See,
I loved how he added a command line
interface for users to input their images.
The coding challenge for this video is
to use three different inputs instead of
just one to train your LSTM network
to predict the price of Google stock
detailed during in the read me
poser gambling in the comments,
and I'll announce the winner in a week.
Please subscribe for more
videos like this. And for now,
I've got to count my stacks of layers,
so thanks for watching.